situé à proximité de la mer est
traversée par le fleuve gotha half la
ville de göteborg a une histoire et une
économie étroitement liées à l'eau c'est
donc tout naturel dit on ici que le
réseau de transport en commun déjà
composée de tramway et d'autobus offre
aussi le service de bateaux
voici donc au milieu du plus grand port
de scandinavie la navette fluviale de
göteborg sept jours sur sept du matin au
choix ces six traversier bleu et blanc
relie la rive nord à la rive sud du
gothard
ils peuvent accueillir 300 passagers et
80 vélos en même temps arrivée dans le
paysage il ya 25 ans avec les nouveaux
développements au bord de l'eau
aujourd'hui les bateaux sont bien utiles